we know a lot now about the moon that we
didn't know back in the Apollo days or
even really just 20 years ago on
Thursday Jeff Bezos unveiled a lunar
lander from his company Blue Origin that
he says will help the u.s. give back to
the moon and to colonize space NASA's
first NASA rather first landed there
nearly 50 years ago when the Apollo 11
astronauts touched down on July 20th
1969 one region of the country that
played a special role in training for
that historic mission and a half-century
later the city of Flagstaff Arizona is
still celebrating Mission Control might
have never witnessed this if not for the
vision of men like Eugene shoemaker it
is safe to say without gene shoemaker
the moon landing as we know it would not
have existed as we know it there
probably would have been a moon landing
a pretty big claim but that's the way
geologists Evo Luke EDA and Jerry Shaba
remember it in fact they say their boss
a top gun at the US Geological Survey
made a lot of stuff happen on that
historic mission originally they didn't
even want him to pick up any didn't want
any television yeah are you kidding I'm
not kidding we've worked very hard here
to use television in our field exercises
and show them how valuable it was I mean
can you imagine no television the famous
steps down you know as bad as they were
as bad as they were that is absolutely
iconic as the story goes shoemaker had a
lot of convincing to do he had to
convince NASA because originated was
just a raw plant the flags
it seems so Elementary to us today they
didn't want to take a rock hammer they
didn't want to take anything hurt their
suit and poke a hole in her suit they
didn't want us to even photograph the
rocks Jean would talk to people there
about the fact that there's no point in
going to the moon unless you're going to
do some science
Carolyn shoemaker jeans widow knows a
thing or two about heavenly bodies she
helped discover one a comet that broke
apart in 1994 and crash-landed on
Jupiter bears her name what was the
sales pitch he delivered they got them
the idea of that man could do a lot on
the moon if they were given the chance
shoemaker found that chance in an
Arizona town called Flagstaff nestled
between Phoenix and the Grand Canyon the
town is in full celebration of the moon
landings golden anniversary yeah this is
the homage to all of our work associated
with getting people to the moon Jeff
Hall is caretaker of the Lowell
Observatory which has artifacts from the
Apollo mission on display and this is
the ghetto this is the guestbook
astronauts came out here and sign it you
can see Neil Armstrong right there
flanked staff provided the astronauts a
near perfect venue to see what they were
gonna run into on the moon now we're
coming up to the old Clarke telescope
dome Lowell's telescope one of the
oldest in the nation helped geologists
map the moon for the Apollo 11 landing
you only get one shot when you're up
there on the moon and you better get it
right and this was a perfect place to do
that but Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
Michael Collins weren't geologists it
was up to people like Shaba and Luke EDA
to train them initially they were not
that enthusiastic about doing geology
they were jet jockeys I think the term
is fly jocks well you can select
whichever term you in any case they were
not particularly interested but once
they got into it they found out it was
really a lot of fun in other words they
got a crash course in geology they
trained at a near
cinder field and steady rock formations
at the meteor crater a breathtaking hole
in the earth nearly 4,000 feet in
diameter and more than 500 feet deep
it's believed to have been created from
an impact approximately 50,000 years ago
and Eugene shoemaker used this as his
laboratory to show the astronauts how to
identify the different rocks once they
got to the moon meteor crater tour guide
Jeff Beal says they didn't have much
time to learn they were here for about
two days out here at the crater day two
days actually I was but the trainees
also brought common sense Buzz Aldrin
actually walked past this Kaibab
limestone and ripped his spacesuit open
so they realized that they had to
redesign their spacesuits make it much
tougher coming up on five minutes with
that knowledge in hand they were off but
there was no guarantee they'd have a
chance to use it I was watching this
guys in Mission Control saying you've
got to pick a landing site you know
really soon we're running low on fuel
and very calm Neil Armstrong just kept
flying until he found a safe place they
said you had 30 seconds it's 20 seconds
a few he got down to six or eight
seconds before he landed the limb was
that close all of it was captured on TV
while Walter Cronkite anchored CBS's
coverage from New York his colleague
George Herman broadcasted live from the
USGS and flags death but Gerry Shawbury
was doing his own thing from Mission
Control in Houston
I was watching their heartbeats because
I had nothing our crash Neil's was going
just barely over an average rate Aldrin
was going like this the eagle has landed
everybody was crying crying I wasn't
sure what what dimension I was
all that science all that know-how
continues to inform those here in
Flagstaff where the Mission Continues
these cinders simulate the moon's
surface I mean with a renewed pledge for
a space exploration the USGS is once
again training astronauts Lauren Edgar
has already started the countdown so
they'll be training in the same spaces
and places that the Apollo 11 team did
absolutely and so I think it'll be
pretty inspirational for them to be
literally walking in the footsteps of
these explorers that went before them
and hoping someday to you know go back
out there and make their own boot steps
and that brings us back to gene
shoemaker he really wanted to be the
first man on the Moon yes a medical
condition denied shoemaker from any shot
of getting to space but after he died in
a car crash in 1999 a lunar probe
carried his ashes there your husband is
the only human being who's buried on the
moon yes I tell you it's such a
full-circle moment they're still
learning so much from those rocks yeah
from 1969 to 72 they collected 842
pounds worth of lunar rocks core samples
pebbles sand and dust and all of them
but three were open they are open
they're unsealing three of them this
year in celebration or commemoration of
the 50th anniversary and they were just
thinking you know the technology might
be there where we can learn even more
right about the lunar surface and it's
words giant achievement that great peek
behind the curtain thank you